bye
hello and welcome to uh our stream of
marvel's avengers
coming to you from australia where the
game is
out we see it all around us more and
more
every day let me know how the audio is
i'm just the avengers weren't like that
i believed it in my core
i keep thinking this has to have
happened for a reason
maybe this is what i've been waiting for
maybe i'm
finally part of something bigger
wow i don't want to talk over the
dialogue for you
god are you excited i'm excited
i can see the bird job oh look
there's a little one it's about time
oh these seats don't recline
it's so beautiful huh why call it the
golden gate bridge if it's not slow let
me put it
[Music]
i bet their stories are all amazing
competition is what makes us stronger
what if they don't like my story what if
it doesn't fit in
oh yes i will turn on subs
when i get out of this your brother said
you had googly eyes
what but i thought your eyes were the
most beautiful things i had
ever seen
we are all unique kamala you should be
proud of who you are
i love you what a kitty i love you more
and i'm pretty sure you're gonna win but
i hope he doesn't die
oh could you imagine uh the winner
for best fan fiction ever is avengers
versus the evil sewer lizards by kamala
khan
and the crowd goes wild
that's the spirit
promise me something we don't lose oh
i'll always be good abu okay no beta
good isn't a thing you are it's a thing
you do
that's my god folks we're approaching
the avengers west coast headquarters on
the left
so this is right from the beginning so
that's a good question
maurice i don't know
i think you have to do uh some tutorial
stuff on your own
from what i've seen
hurry up let's go right all right hold
your horses so that's probably what
we'll play today
it's like about an hour a bit more of
all its tutorial stuff
this is amazing this is amazing
what else is amazing
turning on subtitles
yes please yes please
okay fan fiction contest here i come
it looks free to split spread
should we just [ __ ] around and
photograph whoops look i've already
sworn that's what you get when you put
an australian on a live stream
it's just a horrible mistake honestly uh
i don't think that we need to do this uh
you hit me up in chat if you just want
to see me as photo mode
otherwise i'll probably just play the
game to avengers day
uh yeah this came out at midnight in
australia finalist can i get your name
kamala khan and this is my dad yusuf
the cons great make sure to check out
our comic scavenger hunt
collect all five and get access to the
vip balcony once you've collected them
all just scan your phone at the elevator
and i think this version of the game is
actually like 150 don't you have enough
there's a lot of skins the vip balcony i
have to
um cool okay comics oh my gosh look at
this
tactical awareness that seems like a
thing that we want to use
uh by the way if i'm bad at this
well i'm stuck in the door it was
terrifying it's uh i'm blaming it on the
controller
because i play pc games and this isn't
out on pc till tomorrow even if you have
early access so
that's my excuse and i'm sticking to it
ah um
abu would kill me if i brought home more
plushies
is it not letting me play oh wow she's
just like i'm not allowed
okay um alright looks like we can do
this let's do this instead
happy birthday let's do this okay we're
gonna hulk smash for your birthday
oh god i hope that was a good one
there you go that one's for you
this is this digital comic book
all right we're one comic down like two
minutes in
now to find me out geez we're killing
this guys
all right this is really cool this is
like disneyland i feel like we're really
close to her shoulder
i guess it's just that actually game
kind of perspective
oh sorry i the audio just dropped out a
little bit there oh what's that
are there any discounts for vip reality
the ice cream is free sir
yes thank you jean-luc and rob for
pulling this together
and um for not judging me because oh
here we go
okay if you guys are looking to have a
go at me for not being able to aim
this is your opportunity
all right come on come on
come on jessica pull it together not on
the live stream
oh look a green guy was in the way that
wasn't my fault
that wasn't my fault at all uh i assume
this has
levels of aim assistance
look we'll be okay i think we can make
this work i believe in us
i believe in my ability to
oh gosh
and you just accept it and move on and
that's 100 what we're gonna do
that's fine that's just fine
no i already got this comic i need the
captain america one okay
i like the way collecting comics this is
adorable if you get doubles you want to
trade
i think your game is out in early access
now but it's out like officially in like
three days so if you didn't
pre-order it to get i think it's like
one to three days of early access
depending on the platform
don't quote me um i am iron man
then i think you don't get the early
access but it's still out this week
so i am iron man
i am oh
no this one's all out we waited too long
oh my gosh
repulsor gloves how many of you are
watching hopefully not too many
maybe we can just you you you work with
me you guys are good
in 15 minutes to be pre-ordered there
you go um
um please let me know who your favorite
avenger is because thor is my favorite
avenger
oh and we can fight about it very small
and hard to see
there is no need to cower before a son
of odin so i
understand i'm gonna keep turning to
talk to chat so forgive me what was your
name
oh oh my gosh this is so cute and what
is that thing you are holding
oh it's a high-density muon bean a model
3 repulsor club it's tony stark's
first love wow
thank you odin's beard
about as intimidating as the man himself
hmm
i don't think that's chris hemsworth at
all
behold a true weapon that needs
no improvement she
oh actually doctor strange is really
good
she be worthy shall possess the power of
the tough one
indeed the difference between stocks
trinkets and
the gods might yeah because those are
god that's why he's my favorite anyway
i guess we don't have to fight about it
every hero has to start somewhere all
opinions are right
yes yes of course you are very wise for
one so young
thanks thanks so real
come on sorry i don't know why this
closed captions
it didn't turn them on
that's really cute i can't believe i
just met
the god of thunder mind blown
comic books prize focus
ain't that just the way you know
sometimes
less like that this is out too
oh no this one's all out the shield cap
used in world war two to smash hitler in
the face
this is so cool you're in the way rude
i'm sorry
this contest should only be for the real
fans oh no they're gatekeepers
what makes you think i'm not a real fan
i just follow
kamala you really think that the
avengers read your little story
get out of here
it's really made
and the mob and the press
in the whole world tell you to move
you plant yourself like a tree beside
the river yeah you tell them come off
and you say no you move
what
slide it
okay all right sweetie
great yeah that's okay oh my god
it's mr america thought that was pretty
oh yeah he's going to come back for
us
thanks i'm guessing you're a captain
marvel fan flounder brunette
she's off planet but she would have
liked to meet you sorry you're a captain
america
i'm kamala come along with me yeah she's
wearing captain marvel [ __ ]
come on come on
your story had the evil sure the sewer
lizards
yeah yeah yeah but we really got a kick
out of that one
said they actually had a sewer lizard
problem on asgard once
you're ready everyone submitted i gotta
stop saying cute but it just is cute
so cool hey cap we should oh my god
why is everyone here have you seen thor
he should be here by now
uh i saw him i i saw him yeah he was
over at the stark booth
but he's probably not there anymore
because they saw him leave
allow me to introduce one of our
esteemed contestants this is kamala khan
expert on all things evil sewer lizard
oh all right hey that thing you had me
do with the storm drain cover
pretty bad ass i mean it's nothing
compared to what happened between you
and madame hydra
that was wild
we should head to the stage right yeah
look this is a long thing
i also feel like um i just sort of
wishing the avengers have better things
to do than
hang out at this point but you know
that's fine
that's nice i guess um
it's very cute it's very annoying can i
try
give it a go all right here we go
and now we have the god
so close hey almost worthy is still
pretty good
here you come thanks
done vip balcony here i come
where are we going now
where are we going tactical insight
let's go in yeah
ah okay cool
more comics i believe the action
will come soon from the tv
sick terrorism was meant for the people
not some toy for billionaires it still
can be
stay focused on what matters
our work is going to change the world
george
i know you don't like the pageantry but
it will be worth it
you want control profit we won't let him
gosh this is your moment
with stark's funding and your mind
you'll be a hero
to all those people can't you see
we are so close here you are
bruce
there's always work to be done
what is it nothing it's some
little thing just getting some strange
readings off the uh the reactor george
maybe you were right maybe we were too
hasty to put this on
maybe we were do you think we could run
over the numbers
just
all right that was weird okay i'm doing
back here
what am i doing back here there's a
comic dispenser back here
lost sure let's get you back to the mail
you didn't want me back there you
shouldn't have put
comment dispensing i already have this
one oh what do you want
hold on maybe i could trade this game's
just like
no hey i got the comic you wanted
awesome trade you pleasure doing
business with you
thanks
that's it oh i got a wall now to get up
to that vip okay
good job me um remember
and that's pretty much the game uh you
collect five pumice and
um director nailed it wow direct
everybody's here
that your helicarrier's reactor might be
incapable of containing this
terrigen we know we wouldn't be moving
forward if this wasn't completely safe
the chimera delivers the safety and
protection of the avengers and shield
combined
thank you
bruno is never gonna believe this
oh hey kid be careful oh
okay okay yeah you probably should be
careful
um all right wow that seems like a
pretty
dangerous thing to have in here maybe
around children
um but cool later this is the elevator
to your fancy balcony
it needs your phone scan okay do you
have your complications oh sure yeah i
can do that
i love playing games on stream you're
just looking at four things
and succeeding at none of them open
sesame comic book overlords okay
um we've achieved balcony so that's good
that's a good start i mean
you guys might be here to see like
lighting and flying and stuff but
we are going to a balcony so
don't say we never do anything fun for
you on
every livestream oh my gosh i'm facing
the wrong way
who thinks something dramatic is going
to happen we're also unveiling a new
clean energy like something's going to
explode
i'm told it's quite powerful stuff and
to explain how it looks
the man who discovered it all dr george
talked about
[Applause]
thank you
captain rogers the chimera
is powered by a new mineral territory
three years ago i found a strange rock
yes in the san francisco bay upon
further tests
it was clear this mineral
oh i told you something was gonna happen
hello san francisco the city of five
people
good food and no parking
i am working on the no parking thing
nice bag
oh my gosh there's a lot of controller
[Applause]
all right
yeah you should get out of there all
right here we go
i mean i think we're getting into the
action now oh look we've
assembled yeah
just in case on it
okay okay
are you waiting though can i play
obviously
we're gonna let you catch up
this just got a whole lot more
interesting let's make this quick
[Music]
okay i think the chaos
okay oh a quick time of it oh no it
wants me hold it
oh my gosh okay they're letting me
control the game
time to be allowed oh all right
okay i can dodge i can hit what else can
i do
i can get it
future where we have this game you guys
will have it in like
two hours what did it say
the heavy attack oh okay thank you
all right don't kill the civilians
why would you ever do any other attack
oh what was that do i have other buttons
stand for reason what i do
i
[Music]
i guess you play co-op because what
should i use
my super ability color is super ability
no i guess not
well that one works
okay that's working just fine
come back to me
all right um oh
it just keeps like putting things up
pretty much everywhere and then
maybe they let you do those are
important oh
okay so i'm just flying automatically
and all i can do is aim and shoot with
the same button
which those rockets
goodness gracious which one of you b
movie extra shot at me
all right now we are the iron man oh my
god
the convoy is carrying
oh
oh where'd that guy go i thought it was
a guy there would be running away by now
can't check the feeling we're playing
ketchup shake that down
too far away all right
let's use our
it's probably not called the super chest
attack but i'm feeling okay
oh god i mean i guess we could attack on
the ground too
oh okay okay okay
it back i guess this is just a basic
seven different attacks every hero has
kind of thing
cap that ship's not ready for flight i'm
so sorry for my controller
the security protocol pilot has taken
over
those weapons can't get into the city
copy that the god ray
oh i like that too
okay we're up oh oh yeah i want to be
bruce oh i wanna
because you know what's so great about
being bruce um not having to aim
okay okay okay hold smash let's smash my
splash
oh i guess there's no oh that's
interesting
it doesn't look like this might not be a
light attack
is there oh no there is
okay we are smashing oh
fire oh
i wonder hulk can dodge probably not
really
oh no we can jump okay that's good
okay okay i'll jump
get out of the way all right this is
quite a thing there's just so much
happening
annoying
oh there was no one there really didn't
quite smash in the right
instead of running because he's so
slow
we almost didn't make it but we did it's
okay
oh
me
anyway if you're new you've probably
noticed we're playing avengers
um the game is out in australia
dangerous it's out really soon
weapons were meant for the good game is
that supposed to be a joke
get your heads in the game
cap what's going on over there not sure
not it seems like the reactor's
malfunctioning
i'm getting strange readings on the
monitors like we're being pulled to a
heat signal in the bay
[Applause]
oh my god okay now we're kept in time
all right r1a we can do that let's do
that
oh do we need to aim not really
the chimera is under attack evacuate the
civilian all right
all right all right all right we got
this we got this we got this don't worry
everyone
we are we have this
under control oh yeah we're a shield guy
do you really guess you have to walk in
here
can i use my shield thing again i want
to use it you're trying to hijack the
chimera
where can i
oh look at that
it's a problem hey that's pretty cool
that's actually really easy to execute
i need an update the reactor won't
stabilize um
cap does feel really good i like the
ease of this dodge
that you can just like keep pressing
into them
it's extraordinary okay this feels like
a job for a
thing i just bought i mean the thing i
just charged
yeah let's get them oh i only got one of
them
oh no
[Applause]
oh this seems dangerous oh no i want to
get that guy
oh there we go what's happening out
there
[Applause]
if i hit it even when i'm somewhere else
it just seems to zap me over
oh there we go
we're doing it we're doing it we're
doing it we're doing it we're doing it
brooklyn brawler
let's have a look shall we yes
okay
we need to get that detonator that bomb
goes off it could liquefy everything
within a 10 mile radius
what are we waiting for
oh here we go she's older running you
wonder
the face of the fridge is secure
yeah the closed captions appear to be on
so you're getting like
the real descriptions oh that's
you know i was hoping to fix you
yeah well i'm never here oh did that
say did that tell me how to dodge
i feel like that should be hitting his
head don't you it feels like only his
feet are activated
i don't know i'll play for him
i've only been playing for like i don't
know half an hour
45
oh that wasn't so bad oh don't look at
me don't watch me again okay
could everybody look away while i am
guacamole
hey that was just not hitting him at all
for
no perceivable reason
okay okay we got this
wow oh that must be like a last second
okay what the hell is happening
how that's just not connecting even
though i'm literally on here
thanks a little bit okay hold on
okay maybe i shouldn't try to chat
oh that seemed like a good little swing
do i does she not have a superhero
oh no did i die oh no i did okay
i don't know what that meter is that's
the top of it
it seems like something i should
probably know
i could seem to say in the beginning i'm
sure you guys are giving me tips on the
thing i'm not reading
oh i almost squirt oh it's this one is
it
r2 all right
all right what's r2 we're gonna get our
tube now mate
oh how about that let's be frustrating
oh there's bombs everywhere okay get out
of there i walk boys
just like constant indicators
[Music]
okay here we go oh okay i think maybe i
need to just attack you now
so where is your investigation left you
oh no it's jump to like a
and this smells like this
all right all right that was very
dramatic wasn't it
okay i guess you saw that coming huh
you think you've won one
look around romanov the world will
remember this day
the day they're heroes what do you mean
we're winning we're doing fun
um welcome welcome home
this is marvel's avengers and you are
watching from gamespot.com or
youtube.com forward slash games but
damn it yeah steve can you hear me
get the hell out of there okay
[Music]
screw this
it hasn't let me free yet but if i get
to the map i can show you stuff
oh geez at least they're by faking
oh boy that was really really dramatic
five years ago the avengers paraded
dangerous
untested technology causing damage on an
unprecedented scale
yeah they do that our beloved captain
america was
killed during the attempted theft of
this technology
thousands of other innocent people died
and many more
still bear the scars of what has come to
be known as
adec hundreds fell sick
encased in strange cocoons only to
emerge with
dangerous otherworldly powers with no
known cure
the disease has spread across the
country and while both shield and the
avengers promised to rectify the
situation
it was dr banner's testimony that
brought about the end
of an era you so-called heroes
transformed san francisco
into an infectious gas-filled quarantine
zone you unleash
disease powerful traffic throughout our
nation
many still lay dormant unidentified so i
ask you again dr
banner do the avengers pose a danger to
society
yes their activities outlawed the once
mighty heroes disbanded but out of
tragedy is born hope
after the government liquidation of
stark industries dr
george tarleton himself a victim of a
day
and founder of advanced idea mechanics
thinks
science is the solution to our nation's
problems
i wish i knew what happened to captain
rogers that day
but i was nowhere near the reactor room
i don't have those answers but i can
promise you this
i will use this second chance
to make you safe aim
will i have audio like
comforting words to those families torn
apart by the disease
but is he too confident many criticize
ames tactics
this so-called resistance army grows
stronger
every day this is phil sheldon reporting
live
on the a day anniversary i can't see the
revolution
yeah he's a playable character oh wow
she really likes captain marvel
come on where'd you guys go
there's gotta be a clue here somewhere
she on reddit oh she's on reddit
amazing
hello there um
some of the attacks don't feel like they
connect that worked as well as i wish
they did
oh retro stark
but um
i like you can play all the young yeah
characters feel different
the girls are leaving for the mosque
retreat in a couple of hours
it's still not too late to meet them at
the bus it's tonight
tomorrow going to the retreat will be a
good time to get away from
all of this free some fresh air laugh
nakia will be very disappointed if you
don't go
you're right yeah you're right she has
good hair though
i'll think about it good
very good good
there'll be ice cream oh and best of all
no boys so lots of fun you said it
nah just kidding i love you
i love you more how adorable um
you don't get it i don't know what was
in the uh
actually where were we password
hint first love
oh i thought it was letting me do it i
don't know why i would know that
i bet it's like his dad or like
technology or something like this
but it's like power oh right
electricity oh
come on guys
foreign
no way what that doesn't make any sense
oh my god
i can't believe it oh his love is being
iron man
right is that what they mean he loves
being okay
sure whatever i'm not judging no tony
stark
himself it should have been himself it
should have just been me
i guess
um there will be a full review up soon
i'm not doing it
but uh i'm not actually not sure who is
but i got some it will be up
before too long i'm sure better check
this out at headquarters
okay kamala
where are we going i love these closed
captions i feel like we're all getting a
lot out of them
i guess i really kicked the horn it's
nice girl
oh wow gotta get to headquarters and
check out what's on the screen it looks
like you don't have a gun so i guess
we're just running
are we running running yeah okay we're
just going this way shall we
oh i bet we're gonna swing on this jerk
okay
um all right i like when it's
relatively clear which way to run
scramble up walls oh
oh look at that well that's clearly not
the place i should have done it
oh probably with a scratchy zack all
right
this all seems incredibly dangerous oh
look now we're playing mirror's edge how
about that
should i go this way yeah oh yeah
it's flying toasters i don't want to
drop hair i think i would feel oh what's
that
i don't know what it is but i want it we
did
come on we can wait oh it's a comic book
all right okay
hey hello yes oh move
oh what why i'm just doing stuff you
know that part in a game where you're
just like
this seems like the thing to do thanks
for the lift
oh oh sure i understand
because otherwise it will tip back i
gotta push back hold on hold on
everybody
we got this we may not know how to aim
but by god we can solve a puzzle can't
we yes
sure and yeah
good girl there we go all right
tomb raider our way up there okay
parkour oh yeah i missed a really good
opportunity to say parkour
ah back to the olympia it's all hq
it's my mass okay
why couldn't your hq have been at home
what i mean
secret she took someone's spoiler yeah
some
someone's trying to like run a bath and
it's just like
running freaks out over basically
everything yeah
all right girl um
just let somebody try to get me at range
stretch the arms for those oh she's
gonna stretch
[ __ ] dude can i do any attacks uh none
of my buttons do anything if anyone was
wondering
not yet anyway looking pretty worn out
wonder if they make any for super sized
punches thank you gabriel
i appreciate your support you guys are
always so supportive
i i would have gotten this on uh i guess
we're moving this out of the way huh
on um pc but
it's not where are we going
what's oh up yeah okay
um but oh
oh we didn't quite get in the hall did
we no we didn't it's okay
that's what next time is full
i don't know she got all the stuff here
with her elastic arms i assume you have
to hold the hold
i guess that makes sense since it
literally says the word hold
for some reason they didn't tweak with
me who needs high-tech security when
only i could make
that jump you only you could make that
jump
um yeah okay nobody tell her nobody tell
her
i mean i couldn't do it see what we've
got
the chimera this must be the reactor
room security footage
dr tarleton we never trusted that guy
you're supposed to be on the command
deck uh this is out in early access
now and uh in not early access in i
think
two to three days depending on what
region you're in
no way charlton's healed him
freaking tarleton there's no malfunction
he killed cap oh my god he killed cap
what tiny dancer
oh oh no
so how old is she like 13
it's five years later than when she
looked like she was like eight
she might be fifteen heroes park
i don't know this could be a trap
but what if it isn't but what if it is
though
last known resistance face
yeah i i can't imagine cap's dead
it seems unlikely someone needs to see
this
yeah elton john is the mastermind of
this game wouldn't you definitely play
that game though because i would
oh my gosh just be smart elton john is
my goodness okay
should we look at the menu uh oh i don't
even know if it has a map menu
nope i guess it doesn't oh no it does oh
gosh this is all new to me
so let's take a look
reassemble so at least you guys can get
a look at this
okay we got light attacks they got menus
you probably know this if you'd already
seen oh look at me i can't even
do the thing um okay
wow this looks like it gets pretty
complicated
all right damn
melee gear it's like a whole outfit
do we have any i guess not
oh we have a lot of cosmetics
damn gosh look at all those
outfits i assume they have them for
every single one
okay well let's just be chill for now um
all right and we got our comics
all right so it looks like this is where
you could play with friends
so you've got to get through looks like
it's about an hour of gameplay
and then go nuts and then can we do
stuff now nope still doesn't want me to
do anything
all right well i guess we're going down
that way huh
i thought she was saying down i go i
guess and then she was gonna fall
not that she like had a handle on it
okay i feel like we could just drop
your superhero you'll be okay
sounds like a knock on the door i'll get
it
all right dun dun dun dun
that thing looks tough
i feel like i shouldn't try and
walk past the window right now
i bet you can't read the comics but i
promise you i will check before i
stop streaming
today do we just wait for them to go
away oh well i didn't have to watch that
i didn't have to watch that at all oh my
god wow they're just down there
see the combat like
my take on the combat at least so far
changes drastically based on
um which one
i'm playing as
i i prefer some of the avengers than
others based on that oh
look at my arms
i'm kind of an avengers noob apart from
the movies i almost didn't do that right
oh okay can we kill that no we gotta
keep going okay that's fine
first time heading to the park this way
uh up forward i guess forward i guess
is 100 what my commentary for this game
would be what else you'd be lying about
oh man so this is kind of like
spider-man wait so
can i see them is there no
like map am i crazy
kind of
oh wow emotes
oh i guess that'll make sense if you're
anyway let's keep going
uh okay i guess that was just to get
that thing maybe i go over here now
yes i'm in australia thank you
i'm australian an australian person
just like chris hemsworth my best friend
willow excuse me
that was me clicking the button
the game's just like not
well now you get to see what happens
when you die
oh i'm sorry
uh
okay okay it's okay we we have this we
have this
wow this is a really long long screen
i guess this is the punishment maybe
this is the time you can think about
your mistakes and um
try to be better next time
okay this game ain't gonna get the
better of us
no way no how okay i jumped
and jumped okay yeah well that's what i
did last time
what was i thinking your
hands looked like there would be a lot
of people not graceful
made it okay get to the cap station all
right
oh he's all tippy heroes park
it's been a while i am on a program i'm
here all the time when i was a kid
i'm just reading chat and running so
if i mess up look there's another i'm
staring this place really good excuse me
clinic
such a waste oh
stock sucks everybody's a critic
slash vandal
okay was there anything back here
we're completionist and need to look at
everything
let's go this way all right
yes ps4 pro this game is out
very soon we're in the mud i shouldn't
have gone this way
i'm gonna ruin my shoes
all in humans all missing hmm
this is what albie's really yeah what
does everyone think of it so far good
question
should be a good place to stake out
cap's statue up ahead
yeah i like this story too actually
i think framing around her is super
interesting
um i think it would be really
fun to play co-op that's how i would
like to play it anyway
so you know maybe i should have found
some friends before this strain
can only do what we can do
that is that cat is that
no he's too young is he no
i'm sorry um tiny dancer
hold me closer
rotten youths
it's definitely not captain america to
those of us playing at home hey hey
are you going home
oh my gosh co-op would be hectic we just
got here
hey want a drink no pee a brusher
say no what are you paying your respects
i'm just taking a shortcut that's awful
shortcut come on get out of there
right cool later
she glider bro so we want them back huh
so they can kill more of us what no no
no no what is it then and you must get
you going oh my gosh
come on fellas
stop stop what are we
i should have put you in cooler clothes
come on candle kid's got a girlfriend
zach check out her bag what
what the hell is wrong with you yeah
it's clearly
what are you doing my kid brother was
there on a day
he wrote some dumb stuff about captain
america it wasn't cap's fault it's all
their
[Music]
she's one of them oh don't let her touch
you
no no dude um are you okay
that's one way of getting rid of them i
guess
come on let's go yeah we should have had
a um
marvel video game university dancer
right what do i do with this
what are you talking about please just
let me go
aren't you captain america so we
established
there's nothing better than a stealth
section
where are they pointed i don't know
let's go this way oh no
okay where did you come from where
were there
i didn't see any robot guys all right
it's happened we've died again um
but you know i was warned
i was warned by a co-worker
that there is a instant fail stealth
section
so i can't say this wasn't
expected how do you guys feel about
instant fail style sections
let me know in the youtube comments
it'll be my picture they're putting on
that wall bill bill bill
i can't even really tell where they're
looking to be honest with you
is there like a way
how did i get caught last time that's so
confusing
i seem to be okay
oh okay here we go
not going where they're going okay here
they come
okay
[Laughter]
all right we just slip behind them i
guess yeah that makes sense let's do
that
oh oh i can see them there okay good
damn it they're everywhere they sure are
but you know what
you're a tough girl and i believe in you
oh as if you saw me
he's kind of looking this way now so but
where is his
field of vision is my question
oh no okay all right everybody chill
i can't go that way oh please don't come
over here
okay you're both facing that way so i'll
go this way can they hear me or only see
me i have so many questions
can i even go home
all right so then we'll slip past this
guy
don't worry guys i think we can do this
with the power
of
um having faith in ourselves
is that guy going because it seems like
he's not does it matter maybe not
can you guys answer all my questions no
that's my way am i going to keep asking
them anyway yes
oh look it's even telling me where to go
too many girls out front oh well you
shouldn't have pointed
me to go that way because you confuse me
um the standard version of this game in
australia is a hundred dollars
and the deluxe is 130. stupid stupid
so here you go
ah it's about 2 40 in the afternoon so
it's not crazy crazy early but
it's earlier than it is for you guys
um where should we go
if i were me
trying to where should we
okay he's like looking right this way
he's coming up this way
he's going around the back
uh this might be my opportunity okay
good girl
okay oh don't turn around no no no no no
no no no
we turned around oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] okay don't worry it's okay i
don't know who i'm talking to me i guess
this is a huge stealth section
it's yours hope these guys don't swim
can i oh
wait he's looking right at me isn't he
no all right i guess not
okay
what all right
oh no this is way more dude
i mean it was always gonna be way more
oh that's a little bit scary
oh no more stealth that's what you guys
wanted to see right
in answer to how much game of this do we
play it may be directly correlated to
how much more
stealth there is
oh do i need to hurry oh they're coming
down here really oh god okay i need to
hurry
alright go go go go go go
okay so we're not going that way
oh that's really scary that's really
cool you can see him coming around the
corner though
i don't think i would run through a
sewer although i suppose when pressed
okay well the standing here was a
mistake wasn't it
i didn't get behind anything they were
in front of me and behind me
it's okay it's okay it's okay all right
why don't we we'll get to the end of
this and then
if you guys want to see the menus or
anything actually if you didn't get to
see my showing these
unless you already saw those um in the
in the demo this is a lot of stealth
early game um
yeah cool we've been playing this for
about an hour okay well they didn't
throw me back
to the beginning so look little
victories do you think we just need to
hurry around this corner actually that's
what i'm gonna do
yeah see i messed myself up i should
have just gone faster
i like when the solution is to hurry up
oh no no no no no no please no please
no please i don't want to do it okay
okay
um what's this pushing downstairs is
not how i imagined oh okay i don't know
why we want to be in here but
we've got humans looking for a team who
can teleport
okay
okay oh
stretch grapple
oh damn
okay oh that was the close one
oh god okay
um we going up i think we're going up
oh god what was that up please
yes good
looks clear okay
okay cool yeah i'll show you this
don't you love that when you have to not
die for a really long time just to get
to a part where you're supposed to die
because i love it i mean get caught
the load times are more terrifying to me
than
your judgment uh i'm so sorry on the
stream
those symphonies were only following
their security product when it comes to
my deaths
stealing private information is a
serious offense monika
yeah give me a moment
there times is the final bus hey what's
going on
where are you people taking me somewhere
safe
ah forgive me
i know i don't quite compare to my
holographic counterpart
but it's a nice trick for the
shareholders
cool you're a doctor tarleton
in the flesh she shouldn't take full
damage if she's made of rubber
sorry i think you said the earlier words
i didn't steal it
and what were you looking for that would
be cool
too
kamala aim only once
i thought it was mega minded
you know subjectivity unlimited power
that's dangerous
it's lethal a day was a prime example
you are lucky to be alive
i'm not sure how long the campaign is we
can right their wrongs
we can give you back your this is all
new to me this is the first time i'm
playing it
at all so we're in this together
look i i just guessed a password okay i
didn't think i'd actually get in
she is clearly violent her infection
must be getting
worse what i didn't mean to hurt anyone
of course not but what happens when you
lose control again
what happens when you hurt someone
well by being rubber i guess she does
hate me avengers had to suffer for their
hubris
he bummed her out hey were you there
i mean when cap died
space extends yes
luckily monica found me on the command
deck
her regenerative formula saved my life i
didn't play the beta sorry i'm not sure
come on come on
this is the first time i've played this
yes let
aim help you it seems to be running
pretty smooth
um my only complaint would be the lord
times i'll take my chances
damn it george get the girl now
hold on kamala you just outed yourself
as an inhuman
you did that earlier tonight to be
honest
what were you thinking huh join the
resistance become some kind of hero
oh you can't go home
she's very sympathetic i like her a lot
as a character
so far
i hope the other avengers are
as interesting as they've made her so
far utah
the old shield base resistance has to
know what to do
oh crap oh my god it's a big running
section
okay we can do this we can do big
running can't we yes
okay
oh did i miss something no i make it i
have to get out of town
oh my god
okay oh my god holy guacamole
okay hold on we've got this
oh god quick time
dan this game is just like not moving or
it's just
like oh my god oh my god oh my god hit
the button faster
okay
no keep running don't listen to them
it's a trick
oh that i thought i was supposed to go
over there and i
really wasn't and i don't know why i
thought it was i'm normal
oh okay yep and
up and uh
little red little red
screw you that guy okay
wow her hands are so big
[Laughter]
sometimes i wonder what it'd be like to
react normally to video games
all right this looks like a little
combat arena
i guess i gotta fight my way out of town
okay
let's hit all the buttons and figure out
what they do
oh you're gonna tell me okay good uh uh
to the counter
great all right
oh that's what that little meter was
that we saw earlier
oh increase melee damage if we can
counter all right
i would like to counter you attack me
powers
here we go or i could just
hit you
what gave me away
strange combat is recommended okay
oh wow
that's what you would like me to do
my hands are intense oh wow
okay
okay great my favorite great my favorite
amy that's what she was talking about
all right i would like to be high
okay good high is better
i wonder if i can keep
the hands honestly make it kind of hard
to see the screen
they're intense
but at least um you don't have to aim as
well it seems like with their hands
because obviously they're huge
when they come out like it's not like
just a punch
like a little bullet so it's
hitting more like a shotgun than um
than a pistol
come on
say i went on the retreat with you
oh wow bye jersey
i'm definitely not good but thank you
very much
subject eleven i think all the intro
bits are probably just going to be easy
because they want you to with the
exception of us get used to it however
it's the first time you're doing
anything
cells are splitting down the center
creating two separate things i agree i
love it personality
it's like the planarian flatworm only
human exactly
and can retain all the memories of the
original subject
0925 can create powerful bursts of
energy
and and there's at least a half a dozen
with fire based abilities
we're building an arsenal programmable
power under our control
no more heroes no more mistakes
it's time for another dose i feel fine
you're in a coma for six months yeah
earlier you could barely contain your
cough
that is quite a head isn't it a few more
times just a whole formula
whole lot ahead and you treat there's
not enough contouring in the world to
take care of that
they still light candles at the base of
that statue
if not for that hammer i'd have torn the
thing down no i'm not reviewing
why have the public just playing
you're right this version may be a bit
more
potent is it stabilized
almost almost
this is incredible okay
it's just like a big prologue
i assume you can't play as any other
characters in this so it can't be co-op
yet
i would think although it does it did
seem to have social menus
but there's no way you could play as an
avenger right now
yeah no that makes no sense big prologue
you have reached yusuf khan please leave
a message and i will return your call
hey abu so i took your advice
i'm with nakia and the others on the
retreat
can you believe there's no selfie he
would lose his mind
all the way up to this pay phone to make
this phone call
anyway um you're right we're having a
blast
my ps4 sounds like it's gonna explode
i'll be home late sunday
promise i'll be good
love you more
okay
now phone booth yeah who's the phony
gathers her courage thank you closed
captions
what's that 80s and now
gosh oh the river just rendered in there
there it is
that river looks good
oh man how good are the closed captions
i should be narrating them shouldn't i
no
that would be super annoying
um sounds like a blow dryer yeah
all the conspiracy theories online point
to this canyon as a resistance home okay
well they're the only changes let's
maybe if if we can get to the end of it
quickly we might do that
um let's take a look at someone was
asking about the menu
which is not in the settings menu in the
um for anyone who's new we're playing
avengers my name's jess
thank you for joining uh look at this
menu with me
wait oh i have defensive gear i have
something
how do i hide away yes please oh
equip best gear that is a great idea for
a button
i have to say hey how did we get that
good for us
um doesn't look like we have any points
to spend yet um oh that's right you're
asking about the specialty and mastery
skills
ah okay so those are the ones we've been
taught about
so she has an r12 that's a stun
they got tons of abilities down here
ultimate hero support assault
okay cool and then how your movement
works
all right oh hold on there was mastery
you have to go to bed thank you for
joining us
um wow okay so this is your menu when
you're done with the other menus i
assume
yeah hero level 15 required so there you
go
intense okay let's have a quick look
through here
it's weird to me that's a map am i crazy
i know i've already said that i just
don't understand why i can't find one
if i were a map in a video game
where would i be
i guess it's quite linear at least i
know someone's maybe they're like
trying to jump through that hole
yeah thanks for sticking around i know
it's light so you guys
all right well let's have a little it's
like me to travel across the country
chasing rooms
we'll maybe play for like five to ten
more minutes let's just have a quick
look at what's in here if there's
something
aim's out here too this is another
stealth section
i think you guys know what we're gonna
do stop playing
well shouldn't we be able to fight them
anyway you can get more gear by opening
chests
oh maybe that's how i got the um little
outfit for
finally something not made of rock
is this a good sign or a bad one
well that's cool there seems to be a lot
to do more rpg elements than i would
have expected
those menus are really dense the
resistance
this is where they are it's got to be
and here it takes damage that will power
decreases
okay
l1 okay oh so she can heal
that's nice
oh that's like a big punch
okay
if aim got hit first
hello hello
maybe they got away before no
some must have escaped they have to be
around here somewhere
oh the map's on it fine
how about that um well cool i think
that's probably
the right spot to finish we'll finish on
the hour that makes sense uh
fabulous well this has been avengers i
keep loading up this menu
and let me know what you reckon of the
game
uh we will have a full game spot review
that you can where am i looking i'm
looking at my thing and you're right
here
your words are there your faces are here
uh we'll have a full game sport review
going up
on site uh before too long uh thank you
so much for hanging out with me
and yeah keep an eye out for all our
coverage we'll have
um plenty more things and we'll have
plenty more live streams for you
so stay tuned and i will see you again
soon bye